[Music]
hi I'm Toby and welcome to the joy of
mathematics today we're going to work up
towards something very beautiful so if
you'd like to work along at home now's
your chance to grab your own notepad and
pen and you can follow along don't be
afraid by what is already on the board
this is just a bit of primer that we're
going to need to get started I know that
mathematics can sometimes evoke emotions
of fear and people but I really wish it
wasn't that way mathematics can be very
fun and I think that's the side of it
that we're going to see today don't be
afraid by this math I'm going to be here
and we're going to work through it
together I think we're going to have a
great time so let's get into it what we
do have here are some Taylor expansions
for three common functions we have our e
to the X our exponential equations our
cause of X and our sine of X and the
terms which allow us to write out
expansions for these functions to show
you what e to the X looks like if you
don't remember him just something that
grows at almost an alarming rate really
something that increases with an
ever-increasing rate and something that
follows this sort of shape would be
something like my love for mathematics
let's move on to cosine this is one of
our trig functions so if we were going
to do a plot of cosine on a little axis
cosine is someone who starts off maybe
he's born into a rich family he starts
off very high in life but then things
Siddeley get worse and there's a dip you
know everyone has low moments but but
then things get better and in fact
cosine shows us that life is a constant
cycle of ups and downs yeah like I like
to say these low points this darkness is
really needed to appreciate the light we
gave cosine a friend and that's sine
they're very similar people sine unlike
cosine had to work for what he had he's
sort of started with nothing but he
worked up to be pretty great
and then nothing lasts forever he
eventually lost that and he too found
that life is a constant cycle of ups and
downs now you might notice a few
similarities between our functions they
all have these similar terms which are
actually X to the N over N factorial in
the case of costs his terms are the even
terms x squared X to the fourth X to the
6 and ensign the odd terms X cubed x to
the 5 X to the 7 and an e to the X all
the signs are positive we don't have
this alternating positive negative like
we did down here and we have every power
of X so you can see that there may be
some relation between these three people
here it's almost like they are one big
family but it doesn't seem to quite add
up because if we we were to add curse
and sign you know maybe we'd get
something similar to e to the X we'd get
all of the right terms but we'd still
have these minus signs in here so we
can't just do a simple addition to
relate these functions to this one up
here we need a little bit of help and
you know in those times when I struggle
and I need a little bit of help I do
like to you know it's embarrassing to
say this but it was thought to asking my
imaginary friends some people laugh when
I tell them about my imaginary friends
but I'd like to introduce you to one of
them today and that's my friend I I can
be written as the square root of minus 1
no it's a pretty funny little character
to have I times I equal to a negative
number but that's exactly what's
happening here hold on to your
calculators ladies and gentlemen but
it's going to even get a bit stranger
we'll get to that later now we're going
to use our little friend for some help
we're going to actually rewrite this e
to the X function as e to the i-x
that means that anywhere there is an X
here I can replace it with an AI X let's
go through and do that keep our brackets
right so that we know that that whole
term is squared likewise here and there
we go we now have our function e to the
i-x but what do some of these terms do
what can I really do for us let's have a
look so I to the power of 1 is just
going to be I but I squared is going to
be minus 1 that's from our definition
here and if we were to do I cubed that
would be I or minus I I to the 4 would
be 1 and in fact this series repeats
itself between I minus 1 minus I and 1
and we can use that to rewrite some of
these terms so if we have an I squared
and this term here we can replace that
with a minus 1 let's take out that I
take out that bracket and change this to
a minus 1
here we've got I cubed we can replace
that with a - I
I to the fall we can replace that with a
one should leave that anyway
no mistakes here just happy accidents
and our i five well we can work through
this series to work that one out and an
eye to the five would be equal to one
times i that would be i okay now that
looks pretty good we still have though
our imaginary friend speckled in here
and one piece of advice I have used to
always keep your real friends and your
imaginary friends separate from each
other so let's write down this function
but separating out our real and
imaginary friends we can erase this here
like these little devils off
and here we go e to the i-x let's do the
real terms first so he's real he's real
he's real and I think anything that has
an even power will be real so let's put
it in brackets 1 minus x squared over 2
factorial plus X to the 4 4 factorial
and there's going to be an infinite
number of those real terms let's do our
imaginary ones now all of our mention
Arry terms are going to have this eye
out the front so in fact we can just
take the eye out the front of our
brackets what have we got an X minus X
cubed over 3 factorial plus eye x 5 over
5 factorial and an infinite number of
those terms so if we take a little look
at what we're actually working with here
the eagle-eyed ones amongst you might
recognize that this here is really
nothing more than our old friend cosign
of X this is this function
and you also might realize that what's
in brackets here is nothing more than
our old friend sine of X so this is I
times sine of X so e to the i-x can also
be written as cosine of X plus I sine X
that's a pretty amazing so far but we're
going to go a little bit further with it
let me rub this off and make some more
space for ourselves
okay so I've written back up our
equation that we've worked towards and
let's keep building so e is a pretty
cool function like I said it's an
exponential and it's also this nice
number in mathematics I is our imaginary
friend and X is some unknown but what if
we threw in one more curveball here I'm
sure you guys can handle it I do believe
in you and our curveball is going to be
PI many of you would have heard of Pi
it's related to circles in fact if you
knew the diameter of a circle and wanted
to find the circumference or how far
around the outside you look do pi times
the diameter it's a curious little
number and it's equal to 3.14159 and it
keeps going forever
there is really no end to it so it's a
very nice number in mathematics and some
people would consider it quite beautiful
I definitely consider it pretty
beautiful so I want to replace our X
with pi now if we were to do that we
would get e to the I pi is equal to
cosine of pi plus I sine PI now what is
cosine of PI this is our cosine graph
from before now what I didn't mention
are a couple of things first of all you
know you know cosine repeats the cycle
over and over again if he starts up high
at a value of 1 he sinks down to the
value of negative 1 and the time it
takes with him to go all the way back to
where he started
is one a period and one a period can be
written as 2 pi
now you might know a period as a full
rotation if I was to spin around that's
a full rotation or one period of
spinning and you could say I spend 360
degrees if we were to instead stop using
the unit degrees and use something
called radians a full notation would be
expressed with 2 pi radians
likewise with sine he will complete a
full cycle right here and that's his 2pi
so what is cosine at the value of 1 pi
that's half a rotation well half a
rotation he will be right down here at
his minimum at his lowest point
unfortunately that's going to be high
and it's going to be a value of minus 1
sine of pi well where is he going to be
at half a rotation he's going to be back
at the middle back at 0 so this value is
going to be 0 e to the I pi is equal to
minus 1 plus 0 we don't need to have
unnecessary things in our artwork here e
to the I pi is equal to minus 1 now I
think that is a truly remarkable
equation because not only does it have
three distinct beautiful and curious
little constants or variables from
mathematics we have pi our irrational
number that doesn't end e a similar
number to that
that relates to all sorts of things and
crops up in nature all the time and our
our little imaginary friend who we asked
for help all equalling to quite the nice
number of minus one one of the reasons I
think it's beautiful is because it is so
simple and because it brings together
things that seem to be unrelated to each
other
into something with a very clear
relationship some of the most beautiful
equations and artworks you can make in
mathematics
Arlo's simple ones with surprising
results I'm going to run some titles
across the bottom of the screen and
that's going to be areas where this sort
of mathematics and this sort of equation
can come in quite handy these subject
areas are all also courses on the
website brilliant org brilliant are the
sponsor for today's episode so I would
like to thank them for sharing the joys
of mathematics through their online
courses if you would like to dip your
toes a little deeper into the pool of
mathematics then you can go to brilliant
org slash Tibby's and sign up for free
the first 200 of you that follow that
link will also get 20% off an annual
premium subscription this is also your
personal invitation to subscribe to my
channel if you would like more lessons
like this and from the bottom of my
heart I wish you an absolutely
mathematical day
[Music]